oh hey hey hey good to see you here
buddy how's it going ah
hi my name is Peter I'm seven to skin
we're gonna play when Vikings attack and
this is hello I'm crying and I'm I'm I'm
sitting here let's do it are you ready
ready buddy you ready crawl I think I'm
ready oh you ready guys yeah here's your
controller yeah oh thanks friend you're
right well I hope this means no [ __ ] Oh
all the way down
can you really cry uh don't legally copy
to the floppy going to start Oh sounds
good
you've not accepted the terms of this
agreement god that's oh won't you accept
them oh is it turns again cry
I mean especially you understand yeah
you need to send me another invitation I
mean right thank you you're welcome
you're a good boy I have a class okay
actually Liz this actually played out
maybe we just go to farm let's go the
farm I'm scared I'm doing something
wrong okay are you in the game right try
are you in the game I am in the game
that's what let's go I don't know how to
play this but let's do it it doesn't get
you all right which color you fry I'm
yellow all right and can you give it
your the actual Viking give me the donut
[ __ ] yo donut alright alright here we go
you ready you ready
dry I believe in all of you dance if you
are ready look I'm just a just a dude
wait am I hey what is hey happy we're
not cats
oh yeah people I'm collecting people hey
it's kind of Mari with friends play with
a some way is really cool okay what the
[ __ ] oh boy haha
the Vikings are gathering so maybe we
should kill him oh whoa what I got would
throw them I have no friends I'm great
oh yeah no one wants to play with oh you
got friends on your the Vikings
oh yeah come join the PewDiePie party
it's the best party Chris oh to throw
out a free ice cream and no Nicki Minaj
hey yeah oh hell yeah
oh I think I got one day left cran
they're all know guys I kill him oh no
no no no oh yeah I'm trying to continue
yes terrific this is really oh yeah we
get in the Vikings look walk in the game
I missed the whole boat in this cuz I
have a little bit but just just join me
it's gonna be great cuz that last block
here that last fight yeah yeah yeah yeah
sorry sorry sorry cry did not it's
alright it's okay don't worry about it
go go right go right
oh I love my boat walking all the way
white clothes civilians hey I might be
hurry up I'm trying get earlier I want
distracted me okay boat I cry like my oh
no okay attitude don't push me bro shut
up try kill my clone foundation oh oh
it's part of me welcome oh why would you
kill me and all my people why would you
kill oh there's a Viking sorry make some
Swedish people Vikings all the time I'll
get two guys you know I I gotta go in my
Viking power and Viking power or thump
ha ha you how to follow my Swedish
Swedish Fish oh oh there we go we're
back ooh we're buying
so will you hook I'll keep come upon
this superb thank you hello Vikings come
all over the place man gravity they come
over the place
yeah gross I know it's good what are you
this now really smells like we convert
to the green
converts don't kill my guy John John the
readies because we're yeah but I can
just stand there waiting for killing me
where I could just run around ah how
they behold the barrel what now what
you're not so tough now are you huh no
I'm not hey Petey five what barrels
yeah brother two-timer That's not me
that's crying tell you God look these
other buckle whoa what happened oh I
feel so bad for you
where are you just a circle you stay
down [ __ ] I'm sorry I didn't mean to do
anything to you would you like my milk
jug apparently what the [ __ ] it easier
like this okay we gotta wait he's stuck
in the wall I guess oh did we bug at the
game I think you kind of killed me
permanently okay no no if I were there I
would hit you in the face but I'm not no
wait
Oh what he dead though ah oh yeah good
thing I was wearing a helmet good thing
daddy's broke now he's good at me good
we broke it okay you hit hard crying
thank you you're welcome what I live do
you two live bro I do lift bro yeah I
can tell you look for life thank you I
lift pillows pillows yes how many reps
14 pillow reps every morning what I how
you do it how many Prez hey this game is
broken yeah I think we were
goddang it